tell us first about this the this
exhibition that you're doing well last
night we had an exhibition where I was
able to meet Bobby Kennedy who presides
over the water Alliance who takes care
of the waterways and I had the
exhibition last night which was called
the girl jellyfish Lake and that also
I'm doing another pop-up gallery later
on on the 16th and here in New York City
which is the entire collection and then
the news or pictures of you I know
she'll wear shirts with me underwater
naked five million jellyfish
Wow you have a five million jellyfish
all around you yes how do you take a
picture of yourself underwater it was
when you're in the biggest thing I have
to say it was an easy thing
self-portrait is kind of difficult
anyway but then when you're adjusting
light wrangling jellyfish holding your
breath and then have to have like a face
that you're enjoying at all it's it's
definitely not the easiest thing but I'm
really really proud of a collection what
is your connection to to this
organization Waterkeeper Alliance why is
water conservation something that you
care about right now
I mean well being an artist and and
shooting half of what I do underwater
it's a huge thing I would like to still
be able to go in the water and do this
so I mean plus just visiting all these
areas around the world I see the quality
of water like what happens when I return
there year after year and you know it's
so important and they're doing such a
good job for us
and it's really your calls that I want
to support which is why I'm involved
with them how did you wind up getting
into photography I mean you could say
it's somewhat of a natural leap right
you were model so you were used to being
in front of the camera and around
photographers but right how did you wind
up getting into this field yourself that
actually happened way before modeling my
father bought me my first camera instead
lenses when I was 14 and I remember
spending my allowance every weekend on
just buying film developing photos
trying to teach myself so you know it
kind of happened too early on and that's
really just the tool that I used to show
my arts and and show my passion which is
really just spending time with
these animals and capturing them in
their own natural environment Wow
so the self portraiture aspect of it I
mean that's something that's you know
not every photographers doing it's got
to be an incredibly challenging thing I
mean you mentioned being underwater
being surrounded by the jellyfish what
are some other examples of what you've
done
I have swam with great white sharks with
no cages that was not so fortunate I
have to say in any event people say
weren't you scared of the jellyfish and
I'm like considering what I've done
before no not really
really yeah well we're very excited to
see the exhibit it's it's on display may
May 16 8/16 askew place yeah